présent ce matin pour découvrir les
médailles de la Coupe du monde de rugby
2023 des présidents de clubs Yvelines
noires Lionel garrigue président de
l'Union centre 78 bonjour et Olivier néo
9 secrétaire général du Rugby Club de
Versailles bonjour bonjour alors dans
quel état d'esprit vous êtes là on est à
100 jours du début de cette compétition
c'est une opportunité magnifique que
d'avoir cette Coupe du Monde
il faut remercier les instances
fédérales pour nous avoir amenés jusque
là c'est c'est fabuleux on a une
opportunité fantastique celle de nos
réunir autour de la balle au vol autour
de notre passion et il y a une chose qui
est intéressante à souligner c'est qu'on
plus localement notamment on va décliner
une mini Coupe du Monde des écoles de
rugby chaque club a eu un tirage au sort
le nom d'une équipe en l'occurrence
l'URSS 78 a récupéré
[Musique]
à la place des événements des
séances où les Gallois pourront être
présents devant les enfants les enfants
des Yvelines et les enfants des clubs de
plus près de Versailles et voilà et donc
nous sommes à 100 jours de ce premier
match France Nouvelle-Zélande le 8
septembre au Stade de France
[Musique]
et les voilà les médailles de la Coupe
du monde de rugby nous sommes à 100
jours du début de la compétition et avec
moi Jacques Rivoal le président du
comité d'organisation de la Coupe du
Monde France 2023 bonjour Jacques
bonjour alors déjà un mot sur les
médailles qu'est-ce qui a représente bah
ça représente plein de choses en fait ça
représente tout ce qu'on veut mettre
dans la Coupe du monde donc c'est
d'abord et cette Coupe du Monde on veut
du monde de territoires donc vous avez
sur cette médaille au verso en fait les
les le rubans de Mobius qui est
personnalisé à l'image de chacun chacune
des villes hautes qui accueillera la
compétition et donc qui illustre ce lien
social ce lien qu'on veut créer entre
l'événement Coupe du Monde et les
territoires donc ça c'est la première
dimension la deuxième émotion c'est
insister sur le fait que ces médailles
ont été fabriqués à partir de téléphone
recyclés il y a eu 200 000 téléphones
recyclés qui ont permis de fabriquer les
1491 médailles donc ça c'est la le
témoignage qu'on veut apporter à la
société démontrer que cette coupe du
monde alors un impact positif en
particulier sur la sur la production de
l'environnement donc aujourd'hui c'est
un moment très important parce qu'on
dévoile ces travail et c'est le
lancement définitif de la dernière ligne
droite de la préparation de la Coupe du
Monde de Triomphe dessus et on voit
l'Arc de Triomphe parce que l'Arc de
Triomphe c'est bien sûr la France et
l'Arc de Triomphe c'est l'endroit où
finalement on se retrouve pour célébrer
pour faire la fête et c'est aussi
l'autre dimension qu'on veut exprimer
dans cette Coupe du monde ça sera bien
sûr une compétition sportive très très
intense avec un suspense qu'on n'a
jamais connu on ne sait vraiment pas qui
gagnera cette coupe du monde mais on
veut aussi que cette coupe du monde ça
soit une grande fête populaire voilà qui
qui va permettre aux gens de se
retrouver Parce que le rugby c'est ça
c'est du lien social c'est les gens se
rencontrent viennent ensemble au match
qu'ils soient supporter d'une ou de
l'autre équipe et après fait toi en même
temps donc on espère qu'on va avoir une
vraie trêve pendant lesquelles on a tous
se retrouver on va célébrer la fête
autour des belles valeurs du rugby
grande fête aussi qui retentira dans le
département des Yvelines de équipes
viendront s'installer pendant la
compétition dans le département les
Gallois à Versailles les Tongiens à
Croissy-sur-Seine
on sait que vous êtes originaire des
Yvelines ça a une importance aussi pour
vous d'avoir ce lien de partager aussi
la compétition avec les territoires
franciliens à préciser que le choix des
gambases est vraiment de la
responsabilité des équipes en aucun cas
je n'ai été parti prenante dans la
décision c'est vraiment les équipes qui
ont décidé qui ont été séduits par
Versailles pour les Gallois qui ont été
signés séduits par Croissy-sur-Seine
pour les tonsiens mais effectivement
c'est une belle reconnaissance pour le
département les camps de base c'est
important parce que c'est là que vont
loger les équipes pendant 4-5 semaines
selon selon leur parcours pendant la
compétition et donc ils se sont engagés
auprès de nous avoir au moins un
événement voire plus ouvert au public
donc voilà la population locale pourra
voir peut-être un entraînement peut-être
autre chose il y aura une cérémonie
d'accueil qui sera également organisée
pour pour chacune de ces équipes et
chacune des villes donc effectivement
cette fête elle va être pas uniquement
dans les stades elle va être là aussi
dans les camps de base la France
c'est la deuxième fois qu'elle accueille
la Coupe du monde puisque elle a déjà
accueilli en 2007 et on se rappelle dans
les Yvelines il y avait déjà eu les
Anglais qui étaient allés dans les
écoles qui avaient partagé la culture on
peut imaginer cela peut-être avec les
Tongiens une culture du Pacifique qui
peut être assez impressionnante pour
faire découvrir aux élèves de
Croissy-sur-Seine voilà ça c'est
vraiment à chaque ville avec l'équipe de
définir un peu ce programme encore une
fois nous le l'engagement des équipes
c'est au moins un événement après bah
c'est à l'équipe de séduire à la ville
pardon ou au club hébergeant à séduire
l'équipe pour qu'ils aillent un peu plus
loin et effectivement qui qui met en
avant les valeurs du rugby au travers de
leur présence
le dernier mot en un mot votre état
d'esprit là 100 jours du 8 septembre
France Nouvelle-Zélande match
d'ouverture au Stade de France c'est à
la fois une grande émotion parce que
aujourd'hui le trophée obélis a été
vraiment amené d'Afrique du Sud par un
international sud-africain les derniers
champions du monde il y a 4 ans au Japon
et donc ils nous transmettent le
flambeau en quelque sorte il nous
transmettent le témoin nous disant voilà
maintenant c'est à vous à vous
d'organiser cette coupe du monde donc la
France va accueillir le monde donc c'est
vraiment beaucoup d'émotions et en même
temps beaucoup de sérénité parce qu'on
est très très bien préparé on a on a mis
un on a fait un travail exceptionnel
avec toutes les parties prenantes les
collectivités territoriales on est ici à
la région Île-de-France on est accueilli
par Valérie Pécresse et vraiment les les
collectivités sont vraiment derrière
l'événement World rugby la Fédération
française de rugby les sponsors et
vraiment on va faire une très très belle
coupe du monde
Jacquerie Paul merci beaucoup pour votre
interview pour votre disponibilité
[Musique]
avec moi Valérie Pécresse apprécié donc
de la région Île-de-France vous avez
accueilli le dévoilement des médailles
de la Coupe du Monde qu'est-ce que ça
représente pour vous le rugby ben
d'abord c'est c'est une passion
d'enfance
moi j'ai toujours adoré le rugby et à
mon époque les filles ne jouaient pas au
rugby alors du coup j'ai jamais pu jouer
mais j'ai regardé et j'ai épousé un
corpsien donc un brieviste acharné donc
c'est une passion qu'on s'est transmise
de génération en génération j'ai un fils
qui a fait beaucoup beaucoup de rugby
dans sa jeunesse et du coup comment
avez-vous contribué à l'organisation de
la Coupe du monde alors pour moi le
sport d'une manière générale et le rugby
en particulier
ça unit les franciliens et cette coupe
du monde elle va être un grand moment de
cohésion l'Île-de-France va accueillir
une dizaine de matchs donc on va être
vraiment le centre de cette coupe du
monde et on veut en profiter évidemment
pour accueillir le monde l'accueillir
dignement montrer le sens de
l'hospitalité des franciliens et on
espère aussi qu'on va la gagner donc du
coup bah on est très fier on accueillera
trois équipes vous le savez l'équipe de
France à Rueil-Malmaison le Pays de
Galles l'équipe Tonga donc ça va être ça
va être un moment où toute l'Île de
France va se mettre à l'heure du rugby
c'est pour ça que nous avons acheté 5000
places 5000 places pour les jeunes
franciliens premier inscrit premier
service ce sera sur la base c'est la
plateforme la nouvelle plateforme où il
y aura tous les bons plans pour les
jeunes franciliens et elle ouvrira le 23
juin prochain merci Valérie Pécresse à
bientôt
[Musique]